[Musique]
et la porte et quelques éléments
complémentaires qui sont intéressants
mais par contre sur d'autres points bien
particuliers notamment le fameux
chiffres qu'il a dès qu'il a annoncé de
30 à 40 mille personnes présentes sur le
site à 21 heures avec des faux billets
vous sembliez là les réponses sont assez
floues et c'est vrai que il est le seul
avancé ce chiffre pas d'image pas de
témoignages donc c'est vrai que c'est un
peu compliqué on a des rapports la sncf
qui démontrent qu'après 22h il n'y avait
pas un afflux massif de supporters dans
le sur les transports en commun voilà
tout ça est un peu contradictoire
sur sur le phénomène des agressions des
vols qui ont vu là aussi très peu de
réponses donc c'est vrai que sur ces
points qui nous paraissaient les plus
importants qui sont sûrement la cause
des incidents qui ont eu lieu samedi
il reste très technique et pas trop sur
les points sur lesquels nous avons nous
l'avons souligné moi ce que j'attends de
savoir si soit au niveau de la
fédération française soit plus haut
niveau du préfet de police et des moyens
de prouver ce que dit il
le ministre de l'intérieur est ce que
c'est vraiment la cause principale des
développements que qu'on a connus samedi
ou est-ce que c'est pas tout en
enchaînant un enchaînement de
dysfonctionnements qui ont abouti à
cette situation
[Musique]
la france est en capacité d'organiser
des grands événements pense qu'il
faudrait aussi retiré comme leçons de ce
qui s'est passé samedi c'est de
connaître les raisons qui ont amené cet
échec à ce fiasco et de corriger le tir
l'anticiper ce qui n'a pas été le cas
samedi sur certains points donc je pense
qu'il est sur cet épisode doit nous
servir dans l'avenir notamment pour la
coupe du monde de rugby pour les jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
on doit anticiper certaines situations à
l'arrivée le déplacement de supporters
mais aussi de toutes les spectateurs la
gestion aussi de cette agressivité qui
malheureusement qu'un grain un peu
aujourd'hui la société française
aujourd'hui on l'a vu sur une événement
sportif donc il faut qu'on anticipe
peut-être intervenir plus en amont peu
près de 2 des secteurs et pui déclenché
aussi de la surveillance de ces de
cesser ces groupes qui posent de vendre
des problèmes
[Musique]
c'est le président commission la
commission de la loi la commission de
l'éducation qui vont définir si
il serait intéressant qu'on puisse moi
tes personnel serait intéressant qu'on
puisse auditionner d'autres
protagonistes après
on verra ce que donnera décideront les
deux présidents